and here are the nominees for best
performance by an actress in a leading
role
selma hayek and freda
nicole kidman in the hours
diane lane and unfaithful
julianne moore and far from heaven
and renee zellweger in chicago
oh boy
and the oscar goes too
all righty
buy a nose nicole kidman
this is nicole kidman's first academy
award and second nomination she was
nominated for an oscar last year for
moulin rouge
thank you so much
yes now i have to think um
david hare i need your words um
i have such appreciation and gratitude
for this
um
oh russell crowe said don't cry if you
get up there and now i'm crying
sorry
um
stephen daldry you took a huge chance on
me i'm so grateful david haye you gave
me magnificent words to say
um
scott rudin you fought so hard for this
film to get it made
paramount miramax you made it
and um
kevin huvane rick nicida
mark epstein stood by me for so many
years
and i am
just absolutely thrilled to be standing
up here tonight
i do have to say
it was why do you come to the academy
awards when the world is
in such
turmoil
because
art is important
and
because you
believe in what you do
and you want to honor that and it is a
tradition that needs to be upheld
and
at the same time
you say
there is
a lot of
problems in the world and
since 9 11 there's been a lot of pain in
terms of families losing people and now
with the war families losing people and
god blessed them
and i am
standing here in front of my mother
and my daughter
and
my whole life i've wanted to make my
mother proud
and now i want to make my daughter proud
so thank you
you